David, can you explain in the context of your
views on free speech, which content should
not be allowed on social networks?
Okay, so my view on this is basically law
plus logic.
Okay.
There are a lot of different views about when
should content be removed from social networks.
And oftentimes there is a total jumble of
legal arguments, moral arguments, arguments
that use the term free speech in a completely
wrong way.
So let's kind of lay out my perspective on
this.
My starting point is, unless the content is
illegal, then it should in principle be allowed
on unless it falls under certain categories
of behavior or speech that a social network
as a private business should have the ability
and I would argue responsibility, uh, to keep
off of its network.
So if the content is illegal, it should be
pulled, period, no questions asked.
Next we get to stuff like targeted bullying
and harassment of individuals.
I don't want, if I were running a social network,
I would not want my social network to be in
any way associated with perpetuating these
cycles of people who are attacked and targeted
on the internet.
And then it bleeds over into their real lives.
Sometimes people become suicidal.
There are people who have actually taken their
own lives because of bullying that was happening
in great part online so that it can't be used
as a tool for targeted harassment in that
way.
In the same way that if you follow someone
around in real life, much in the same way
that is taking place online, even if you're
not stocking them per se, if you're constantly
attacking them and insulting them and yelling
things at them, you would be able to call
the police and the police would tell that
person you've got to go.
Uh, there is no legal issue with social network
saying that's not going to be the way that
you can use this tool.
That's number one.
Number two, it is perfectly reasonable for
social networks to say, even though it is
not illegal to target people on the basis
of their immutable characteristics, sometimes
in a membership, in what in some States are
called protected classes.
Uh, we are not going to allow it on the platform.
And again, if I was running a social network,
I would not want to see the platform used
to target individuals or to attack individuals
on the basis of their religion, their ethnicity,
their sexual orientation or whatever the case
may be.
I wouldn't allow it on my social network.
If you don't like that, then you can go and
either build a different social network or
find a different one or lobby the social network
to change those rules.
But that's essentially the, my, my thinking.
Uh, I don't think that there is any responsibility
of a social network to block conspiracy articles
or anything like that.
I think once you start taking money to promote
things like, for example, the wrong voting
day via advertising the way Facebook has been
facing lately, I think that's a different
question.
But in principle, if you're posting some kind
of conspiracy or fake news article, um, uh,
as an individual, if it's not, uh, attacking
or pushing bullying on individuals, if it's
not attacking or harassing people on the basis
of their membership in some protected class
or immutable characteristic, I think that
that's fine.
I don't think that social networks should
get involved in policing that, but, but those
would be my parameters.
Um, essentially, illegal content is not allowed.
Targeted harassment, bullying, and encouragement
of bullying both online and in person against
people should not be allowed.
Uh, and, um, uh, attacks on people that are
either, uh, race-based nationality, um, uh,
attacks on people with, with disabilities
for example.
I wouldn't allow any of that stuff on my social
network.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Become a member
instantly.
It joined pacman.com and you will get access
just as instantly to the world famous bonus
show, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.
[inaudible].